von
astromant ob sie wohnen christuskind so
zum im labor zu küren ja ich esse immer
kürzer sind gemacht hat und
wir sind
mitten und wachs
mache
[Musik]
und man
muss einfach mal locker
[Musik]
ich habe die botschaft dass ich komme
mit wdr
startbahn hier gar nicht passen ich habe
mir noch nicht vorstellen dass sie dann
in der badewanne in hocke und und das
trinken
[Musik]
in der stadt zürich kommen pro jahr 5000
kinder auf die welt fast die hälfte
davon in triemli dem stadtspital zürich
in sichtweite zum spital wohnen hier
zuoberst larissa gerhard und fabian klos
lee das paar erwartet ihr erstes kind
larissa ist im sechsten monat schwanger
in ihrer wohnung schaffen sie platz für
den neuen lebensabschnitt
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
verhindern
die geburt des ersten kindes verändert
das leben als paar auch wenn man sich
gut kennt
selbst gemacht und sie wegen spd da
weniger schön
ich wollte lernen ist ewig weiter nicht
einig sind
also eigentlich sie zwölf zusammen
befreundet sie
sämtliche durch fünf gemacht und liefert
genauere durchwachsen man kann nicht
einfach sagen
sozusagen bergpark genau das ist uns
anzuschauen wahrscheinlich ein vorbild
des monats einfach gerade passiert
auch von einer wichtige starke
freundschaft sondern
liebesbeziehung wachse und doris für
männer schwierig ja immer zeit wie weiß
nie wie viel ihr zusammen sind wie es
für mich so
viel länger
krank
[Musik]
wurde
ich nenne
[Musik]
das triemli liegt am fuße des gudibergs
das spital für den grossraum zürich
vereint alle wichtigen medizinischen
disziplinen unter einem dach in der
frauenklinik kommen jeden tag sechs bis
sieben kinder auf die welt
auf der wochenbett station ist heute
hebamme caroline super unterwegs
rund um die uhr kommen in der
frauenklinik kinder zur welt
entsprechend groß ist dass hebammen team
caroline suter ist eine von 45
[Musik]
seit zwei jahren ist carolin suter im
triemli tätig und sie hat schon 200
babys auf die welt begleitet
wer schwanger ist macht sich im voraus
gedanken wo das kind zur welt kommen
soll carolin suter welt in ein paar
monaten auch die hebamme von larissa und
fabian sein
im medizinischen notfall möchte man sich
auf spezialistinnen verlassen können im
stadtspital zürich hat es auch eine
neonatologie und kinderklinik ärztinnen
aller abteilungen tauschen sich zweimal
pro tag über die patientinnen aus am
tisch sitzt auch natalia gondel sie ist
leitende frauenärztin nach dem morgen
rapport macht sie sich auf den weg in
den operationssaal
[Applaus]
gynäkologie ist auch ein chirurgischer
natalia gondel bereitet sich auf einen
routine eingriff vor trotz des
hochspezialisierten umfeld geht manchmal
vergessen dass bei jedem operativen
eingriff und bei jeder geburt auch etwas
schief gehen könnte
ja
[Musik]
einer jungen patientin entfernt die
leitende ärztin ein gutartiges geschwür
in der gebärmutter
schluss an
das museum könne wegschneiden kreuze
gemacht wird sich nur junge wurde nach
hin dass man jetzt viel verschlimmert
produktion des schwimm- und wegnehmen
dann schwierig
der kinderwunsch kam auch bei fabian auf
für mich ist romantik sie wohnen ist das
kind so zum leben dazugehören
also ist ein wenig mit 80 starter und
mit das kind
einer familie meint ich bin die erste
die oft wachse mich sind es sagst für
die familie hey und
familie ist mir alles für mich familie
für mich mega wichtig und
so immer christa sieht gemacht hat und
aus einer familie mit
fabian und larissa sind beide
berufstätig
schon vor der geburt suchen sie einen
krippenplatz das ist in zürich üblich
weil plätze für babys rar sind
[Musik]
fabian ist selbständiger berater er und
larissa wollen hochprozentig in ihren
job zurück und sich die familienarbeit
zur hälfte teilen sie suchen einen
krippenplatz für zwei wochentage
nicht komplett auf wenige zeichen werde
jetzt in das kinder darin sogar zwei
inhaber sein der papi tag ist eingeplant
das ist mir extrem wichtig dass das alte
faktor von ihm kinder der mine sind
die papiere hätten
extrem gute eric abidal komiker hans und
der partie war sehr viel präsenter und
max und sind extrem wichtig also genau
wie minirolle ausnahme wo am anfang
sichere intensiver wirkt sie aber noch
alles mit mega wichtig dass mehr
zusammen seiner familie sind
larissa arbeitet im urbanen kreis 5 in
zürich
die 31-jährige ist vollzeit im marketing
eines internationalen unternehmens tätig
das gegen food waist kämpft larissa ist
mittlerweile im siebten monat schwanger
eben erst wurde sie noch befördert
diskutiert wurde nicht nehmen natürlich
gewusst dass clarissa schwangere
sie engagiert sich voll sid sid am
anfang und sich wirklich
entscheidend ist dass sie in dem moment
wo die stunden die neue struktur vom
team plant wurden ist dass das mittlere
befördert und und natürlich natürlich
einmal kurz weg für das bordnetz und
moderne genau wenn sie zurück und aber
wie gesagt ich glaube privat lage ist
ein teil vom leben und welche nötig sei
dank ist nummer job prominent leichter
wenn man immer präsent sie und ich
glaube aber baby baby bekomme ich habe
es wichtig
im alter
als arbeitgeberin amtlich
in der neuen rolle als marketing
managerin für clarissa zwei
mitarbeiterinnen
führungsverantwortung will sie auch nach
der babypause übernehmen
laptop und dass ich mich als praktisch
programmiert das heißt ich auch vorüber
und ich hoffe immer bei mir ist klar
dass sehr hoch prozentig zurück will im
job sehr gern hab mich freue auf zurück
ins team kehrt zurück zum einen projekt
mini im inneren position aber wir können
nichts mehr und mit ihm mit der uws
bauer
wie lange das sie weder wechsel
offiziell 18 wochen mutterschaftsurlaub
das ist sicher fest dass sie dir zb
und hat immer seine idealvorstellung
noch länger wird
oder nicht ich glaube das sei
dahingestellt
manchmal hat larissa noch mühe sich
vorzustellen wie das leben mit kind sein
wird
mit kinderbetreuung
alles unterbringen
[Musik]
training on the job
und jetzt laufen
es dauert noch zwei monate bis zum
geburtstermin
larissas langjährige frauenärztin hat
sie anstatt spital überwiesen beim
letzten ultraschall schien am herz des
ungeborenen kindes etwas nicht in
ordnung
andere frauen gemacht
wo nicht immer zu
vage und im ried stoke city wo am 10 das
system macht objekt untersuche getreue
im triemli machen um auch wieder bezog
ich habe vom geburtsort
im untersuchungszimmer trifft das paar
heute zum ersten mal gynäkologin natalia
gründe
sie will am herz den sogenannten
ausfluss trakt überprüfen
wenn man diesen nicht sieht ist ein
angeborener herzfehler zu befürchten
[Musik]
das team von skip beruf
das ganze zur
zumal
[Musik]
und
ja die ausfuhr sogenannter ausfluss
trakt im linken
und die muss man sich verändernder
verlauf darsteller
und
ja also es ist so wie sich der linksfuß
net/idea führte sie dann damit ex serie
führen gern dass
die ärztin empfiehlt eine weitere
untersuchung und larissa macht sich in
der schwangerschaft zum ersten mal
sorgen
und besten jeder vergangenen sieben
monate bis gemacht wo
aber sicher nicht falsch aber es macht
mir viel das macht mir sehr viel
das gesunde kinder keine
selbstverständlichkeit sind geht heute
gerne vergessen
hebammen sind für werdende eltern im
umgang mit ängsten eine wichtige stütze
für
carolin suter beginnt kurz vor 23 uhr
die nachtschicht auf decke der abteilung
im stationszimmer verschaffen sich die
hebammen einen überblick was in den
sieben gewehr seelenlos ist carolin
super show zuerst zu einer frau die in
wien liegt
[Musik]
und was sieht den 16 regelmäßig werde
aber sicher noch nicht geöffnet hat die
bürger
die frau fährt noch einmal nach hause
aber nicht für lange
[Musik]
eine halbe stunde später ruft sie erneut
an
kurze zeit später ist die werdende
mutter zurück und diesmal scheint es los
zu gehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im zimmer nebenan ist heute nacht dylan
zur welt gekommen
die nachtschicht verläuft sonst eher
ruhig und ein gewehr saal dient kurz als
pausenraum
[Musik]
oder wenn denn einfach nur dass wir
schnell schnell im stehen schnells
protest oder so und so
viele zum hauptstadt besetzt aber denn
hier mit allen zusammen und so das ist
spitze kraft also vorher schon geht's
für die hebamme weiter zu einer frau bei
der die geburt mit medikamenten
eingeleitet wird
[Musik]
bevor die nachtschicht endet fällt noch
administrative arbeit an
das sind in der regel die längsten
stunden
nach 7 uhr kommt die ablösung nun steht
ein neues team aus hebammen und ärzten
den frauen in den gefäßzellen zur seite
wie wird eigentlich nicht an die
jugend
[Musik]
das triemli bietet heute noch einmal
larissa und fabian auf
[Musik]
eine ultraschall spezialisten untersucht
erneut das herz des ungeborenen kindes
ein positiveres
und
da habe ich die anderen wechselten
morgen
larissas tatendrang ist zurück neben
ihrem job hat sie vor der
schwangerschaft noch ein unternehmen
gegründet sie backt bananen brot in
einer industrie küche in die sie sich
einmietet
[Musik]
findet so schön übernahme wachse
und vor allem wenn es bananen machen
braucht man bruni banane
nachhaltige arbeit ist larissa wichtig
[Musik]
so zu mir gehört wurden im umgang mit
uwe und ich glaube nur wenigen glücklich
im job oder rom im nabu projekt kann ja
alles kurzmann island und das befruchtet
training alles mit genannt
das geschäft soll weiter wachsen auch
mit kind im moment beliefert larissa die
kundschaft in zürich noch selber fabian
wird bald übernehmen
immer mein gott so langsam
gefahren und heiko fischer muss schon
sehr schwach
im moment ist das gott so wie es jetzt
ist
und der logimat
also es sie dass er dass sie plötzlich
muss liegt dass sie plötzlich neben
stosur und liefere und erfinden wir
lösungen dass das erste kind das leben
verändert wird den werdenden eltern
immer mehr bewusst
und die betriebsspannung wenn es
wirklich jungen um die klassische
telefonie
und wirklich aus großes fragezeichen
wegen der negativ gemeint aber über ist
gespannt wie daten das lasergerät
untersagt
es wird ihm saßen die wieder für andere
aber es war
definitiv auch
nun gehts los mit gar nicht dass ghana
letzte fehler erweisen
[Musik]
die entwicklung des babys haben sie auf
dem smartphone verfolgt
wie man roboter
auto wieder hornig
männerhaut vor
65 zentimeter kürzer wofür insgesamt
meter umfang aufnehmen winzige
hauptamtlicher umfangs letzt fried ich
sie und jetzt bin ich gespannt ob das so
weitergeht wie letzte woche
larissa spürt die extra kilos und ihre
einstellung zum job hat sich auch
verändert
meetingdirektor fort und kam im fokus
ich so kann ihnen so konzentriere ich
mir das wünschen die bevorstehende
geburt wird vor allem im labor
und es ist mir auch die angefangene
beschäftigen das ist für als wenig
deshalb will er heute bei der ärztin ihr
arbeitspensum ansprechen
[Applaus]
danke
und zu schwimmen schöpfergottes nur den
10 situation die 50 prozent reduziert
und gleichzeitig als emo zimmer ich habe
hier wirklich stands ihre glaubst du
lang mannschaftlich sehr schwierig und
jasko die erste
wenn die plötzlich liegen
okay
das ist jetzt
das kind entwickelt sich gut
die gedanken an die geburt werden immer
konkreter
plazenta die ich alle hinter und wie
ihnen das sieht man da und teil unter
einer und teilt uns schwarze das ist
doch was wenn man sich abholt super und
extrem geil natürlich gewahrt
also solche gedanken an einen
kaiserschnitt
kino horror gedanke aber
schlussendlich ist
[Musik]
für mich
das wichtigste
ich glaube die stelle geschwächte frau
der positive ich stelle kann und von 80
also froh jetzt aufgebot das ist ja doch
dann irgendwann mal ersehnt und erwartet
und ich glaube dass ich das spüre ich
wie er jetzt so das positive dass ich
sehr gute voraussetzung einen gang
runterschalten
damit ist auch die gynäkologin
einverstanden vier wochen vor termin
erhält larissa ein arztzeugnis und hört
mit arbeiten auf
[Musik]
sie stellten die sache erledigt in die
startposition
wirtschaftslenker unterschied der
strecke
und auch inoffizielle papier
[Musik]
schwangerschaftswoche 8
zum letzten mal mit babybauch
in zürich bläst die wiese und zwei
wochen vor termin platzt larissa die
fruchtblase ein zeichen dass es losgeht
weil die infektionsgefahr bei einem
blasensprung groß ist wird larissa
regelmäßig überwacht der geburtsprozess
sollte in den nächsten 24 stunden
beginnen larissa spürt noch nichts
fabian hingegen etwas
[Musik]
larissa würde lieber nicht einläuten und
hofft dass der wehen cocktail aus
rizinusöl und aprikosen saft über nacht
wirkt
einen tipp bezüglich essen gibt's noch
möglichst scharf
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen sind sie zurück in
der frauenklinik es geht direkt in den
gewahrsam larissa steht aber noch etwas
neben sich
ich war schon mal hier drin waren unser
schönstes und größtes immer
[Musik]
noch nicht vorstellen sie denn in der
tat waren hocker und und das trinkgelage
mit
akupunktur will man etwas nachhelfen
sie haben wird
eine stunde später ist keine position
mehr bequem
[Musik]
loosli
wie viele frauen kämpft auch larissa
gegen übelkeit
[Musik]
ein
die arbeitsschicht von carolin suter
beginnt es ist nun ihre aufgabe larissa
zu unterstützen und zu motivieren
ja
[Musik]
den wehen schmerzen zum trotz larissa
und fabian möchten ein erinnerungsfoto
[Gelächter]
wie lange der geburtsprozess dauert weiß
in diesem moment niemand
larissa klagt immer wieder über
rückenschmerzen
hebamme und ärztin untersuchen in
regelmäßigen abständen den muttermund
der sich öffnen muss
[Musik]
wir wollen ein wenig
das verstanden
[Musik]
das kind liegt nun weit unten im
geburtskanal aber in welcher position
die rückenschmerzen sind anzeichen für
eine besondere lage welche die hebammen
fürchten
magst du
kommst du schaffst das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein sternengucker das kind hat sich im
letzten moment noch gedreht und blickt
mit dem gesicht nach oben das bedeutet
mehr widerstand im geburtskanal
mehrarbeit für mutter und kind und die
beiden geburtshelferinnen
sternengucker brauchen häufig hilfe bei
der geburt zange oder saugglocke
carolin sutter und natalia konnte müssen
abschätzen wie es um larissas
verbleibende kraft steht
haben sich lina extra power braucht
also nicht darauf vorbereitet ist
einfach nur bitter dass oxytocin
moduliert und man sich noch in dem
verstärkt sich zur hand die dich gott
alles genau wie david und tatsächlich
unterstützen
genannt sei wichtig erzählt zu werden
oder gar keinen kopf
da
es hier bisher
noch nie mehr nach libyen auf einem
chronisch ausschuss
nein ich selbst geschaffenes kom kom kom
kom kom ärztin und hebamme setzen auf
das wie ein hormon und larissa starten
es braucht eine letzte press wer einen
schnitt und dann um 20 5 ist es endlich
soweit
[Musik]
nach zwölf intensiven stunden im gewehr
saal ist fiona li na da das gesunde
mädchen hat sich den weg auf die welt
erkämpft
[Musik]
es sind momente für das familienalbum
unglaublich auch
[Musik]
für die hebamme war sein erstes machen
gynäkologin natalia conti verabschiedet
sich nach der geburt und hebamme
caroline suter versorgt mutter und kind
bis sie in der nacht auf die wochenbett
abteilung verlegt werden
[Musik]
ich glaube er hat mir vorstelle dass
wirklich fokus denn oft komplett
tochter dass ich zwei wochen pause
machen das nicht
und die einfach so
dass aufgaben sieht der mia generiere
und
wo die sony erwartet
[Musik]
in der erinnerung von larissa und fabian
wird die geburt ihrer tochter immer
einmalig sein
und im stadtspital zürich geht von alina
als kind nummer 1550 des jahres in die
geschichtsbücher ein
[Musik]